en fait une star sauf quand n 2 jours
par par année à l'extérieur que ce soit
en europe en asie en australie
senez est l'une des têtes d'affiché du
festival il sonic sept produits gt gt un
graphic designer de hamsik
puis j'ai juste découvert la passion la
musique à travers les jeux vidéo à
travers les informatique au succès
fulgurant pour ses dj originaire de
sainte émélie de l'énergie dans
lanaudière
ils vont plus de cent mille billets de
spectacles par année sans compter les
festivals et ses musiques ont été
écoutés plus de 128 millions de fois sur
les sites d'écouté en ligne car on joue
notre comme parce que les macarons celle
de la fac
bonjour notre arc ont reçu le style chez
c'est pas mon mac cela qu'on n'en
profite on a travaillé des arts et des
arts une chanson je dirais que les 10%
même 5% et le temps qu'on est sur le
stage larrère ce soit dans le studio
rencontrez-vous beaucoup voyager cette
année
evenko décide de présenter sa
programmation sur 4 affiche une solidité
en courant de musiques électroniques qui
seront en vedette cette fin de semaine
c'est le dr qui en fait l'acronyme pour
electronic dance music qui au travers
des dix dernières années devenu un
acronyme pour désigner vraiment la
musique électronique très commerciale en
ce 200e évidemment la musique urbaine on
vraiment lui dans le hip hop et de la
halle latin la musique une baisse donc
vraiment une musique qui est dans les
basses fréquences qui appelle beaucoup
beaucoup au défoulement et on se dit ça
on ne fait une scène complètement
underground qui est basé sur la musique
house et techno
les spectacles de dj sont des événements
à grand déploiement
et le scénic attire beaucoup d'artistes
internationaux
bf également la scène à du dj originaire
d'istres ouais c'est quand même gros
combien je suis habitué à jouer de
grandes ça s'est un peu plus dans le
gros meanstream mais c'est vraiment
excitant quelque chose de gros sponsors
l'électronique et un style musical
dynamique en pleine croissance au pays
c'est sûr qu'il ya tellement plus de
projets comme sonnex quand même nouveau
les projets comme puis one qui est quand
même plus ouverts à le grand public
je crois que montréal c'est vraiment
spécial
les musiques électroniques sont
plurielles et des événements comme le
scénic permettent de découvrir la grande
diversité de l'offre alors que pour les
dj c'est l'occasion de partager leur
passion et de faire danser des milliers
de festivaliers sinai bay alexandre
chartier radio canada montréal